atheists are champions of science and
reason who have carefully and honestly
examined the evidence for God's
existence and found this evidence sorely
lacking and now that they've thoroughly
debunked belief in God they demonstrate
their Sober rationality by spending
every waking moment on social media
posting Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy
Sky daddy Sky Daddy but don't let these
endless cries of Sky daddy sky Sky daddy
sky daddyy sky daddy Sky daddy make you
think that these intellectual
powerhouses have simply been programmed
by manipulators using cult tactics no
these brainiacs are as meticulously
rational as a cosmologist writing the
calculus coaster at logic land on treky
get in free day at least that's what
they keep telling me sadly I'm not a
super smart atheist anymore so when I
try to figure out what's going on
all I see is a handful of academics who
will reject any evidence for God no
matter what it is conditioning a Young
Generation to reject any evidence for
God no matter what it is while making
this Young Generation think that they're
just going where the evidence points to
me bonehead that I am it looks like cult
tactics Hey kid do you want to be
special do you want to be part of the
smart group do you want to feel like
you're better than everyone else Jeepers
that would be
swell well then join us and you'll be
part of the smart group you'll be
special golly is there anything I need
to
do just one thing you have to spend all
day every day on social media posting
Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy
sky
daddy Richard Dawkins was once asked if
God did exist what sort of evidence
could God give you that would convince
you that he exists Dawkins couldn't
think of anything he said that if God
audibly spoke to him he would dismiss it
and conclude that he's hallucinating he
said that even if God wrote a message to
him in the Stars he still wouldn't
believe in God because the message in
the Stars could have been put there by
powerful aliens trying to trick him
Peter beian The Atheist philosopher who
was interviewing him agreed
completely and they're not alone let's
hear from the great Oxford chemist Peter
Atkins who like Richard Dawkins before
him was asked about the sort of evidence
that could potentially prove him wrong
here's the charge against him I think at
one level some people might accuse you
of being so committed to ath ISM that
you'd never be willing to countenance
any evidence that might lend support to
a Creator behind the universe and now
the question I'm just interested what
sort of evidence could science or the
physical Universe present to you that
would make you think actually that that
is evidence that there's a a mind behind
this I find that um a very difficult
question shouldn't be too difficult if I
were looking in the Bible for evidence
heaven forbid um I I um would expect to
see
maybe increase in entropy is equal to Q
reversible divided by temperature so
amazing scientific insights in the Bible
that would convince you if there was
literally an equation in the Bible
equation in the Bible rather than all
this wishy-washy um elastic writing that
it pervades an equation that would do it
so so if if there was something like
that that they discovered in the Bible
think probably a for well exactly that
the problem is would it actually make
you oh you'd explain it away interesting
but what if you saw a message written in
the
stars I mean is there anything from you
know is there any kind of evidence in
the universe that could make I mean if
the stars lined up to spell Peter please
believe in me it's about
time I put it down to Madness so if you
saw a message Written in the Stars you
would explain it away just like Richard
Dawkins and Peter
bosan sounds like Peter that there's no
evidence that have persuade you away
from well to be honest I think that's
probably the case at least he's honest
not about the evidence but about the
fact that he's going to reject the
evidence no matter what it is in that
sense do you even have an evidence-based
view if you're actually committed to
atheism a priori no
well I I'm predicting that there will be
no such evidence that's not quite the
same thing as being committed to it a
priori um I I I can't you said there's
no evidence that would persuade you
otherwise I I think it's much more
likely that I would have gone mad than
such evidence would have been provided
you are not helping yourself here Dr
Atkins so so in principle it's
impossible to ever persuade you that God
exists I didn't quite say that I think
he did well what would persuade you I
can't conceive of uh I suppose even if I
died and was confronted with you know St
Peter saying welcome to Heaven um I
probably think I was dreaming so even if
you died and you were welcomed into
Heaven by St Peter you still wouldn't
believe
keep in mind these are the same people
who assure us that they're committed to
going wherever the evidence
points If I Didn't Know Better which I
don't I might think that what they're
really committed to is rejecting
evidence that points in a Direction they
don't like how very scientific of them
so those were a few clips from a
discussion between Peter Atkins and Hugh
Ross during a different discussion this
time with John Lennox people were
texting in questions and Dr Atkins was
asked if there's any evidence that could
convince him that he's
wrong what new evidence would be
sufficient to lead the speakers to adopt
the opposite view so if I perhaps ask
that first of view Peter is is there
anything any kind of evidence that John
could bring to bear that would actually
make you change your mind think actually
maybe there is a God I'll give everyone
5 Seconds to make your
predictions I I I think that's very
interesting I I have asked myself that
question previously you is there any
evidence that would flip me into into
the belief camp and so and I simply
can't think of any shocker I think if I
tell myself that if I agreed with some
evidence then it showed that I simply
gone mad if he ever agreed that any
evidence supported theism he would think
that he'd gone
insane um so it's a serious question but
I don't think there can be any evidence
are you saying your position is
unfalsifiable in that
sense Yes again at least he's honest
about rejecting any EV evidence that he
disagrees with even if there was if I
was standing you know the foot of a
cross and saw the um the resurrection
before my very eyes I would put it down
to hallucination even if he saw Jesus
rise from the dead he would explain away
what he saw he would say I must be
hallucinating seeing a person rise from
the dead wouldn't convince him Matt
Dillahunty said something very similar
in his debate with Mike Lona Mike said
look if I was beheaded in front of
everyone and you saw my decapitated
corpse and then I came back and I walked
in and I told you about my trip to
heaven and I told you about someone I
met there someone who had had a private
conversation with you and I knew the
details of that conversation even though
the person was dead would that convince
you that something
Supernatural had
occurred Matt immediately replied
no the takeaway from all of this
definitely isn't that atheists follow
the evidence the takeaway is that pretty
much any evidence can be reinterpreted
and explained Away by people who are
committed to an unfalsifiable
position atheists aren't educating the
rest of the world on how to go where the
evidence points
the leaders are giving a tutorial on how
to reinterpret and explain away evidence
that they don't like and on how to
psychologically condition people by
making them think that they're part of
some Elite group as long as they go on
Twitter and post Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky
daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy meanwhile the
followers are walking talking whining
proof of that old
saying there's a sucker B warn every
[Music]
minute